c'est dans l'une de ses maisons situées
juste derrière moi qui a été découvert
il ya une semaine le corps sans vie d'un
père de famille décédé d'un tir d'un ba
feu en pleine tête à bout touchant
et c'est également juste derrière nous
mais de l'autre côté de la route juste
là bas au fond qui a été découvert il ya
deux mois et demi le corps sans vie
d'alexia d'aval cette proximité
géographique pose question même si pour
l'instant l'hypothèse du suicide est
privilégiée par les enquêteurs
outre la proximité géographique des deux
affaires l'absence d'armes à feu aux
côtés du corps de la victime interpelle
les enquêteurs jeudi dernier une
trentaine de gendarmes a arpenté les
villages à la recherche de 7,6 en vain
cet après midi à gré certains membres de
la famille ont été interrogés par les
gendarmes
une famille qui déplore l'absence
d'informations de la part des enquêteurs
c'est encore autre chose ne veut pas en
entendre parler
on ne sait pas qu'est-ce qui a eu mon
frère est plus là il ya eu quelque chose
nous bien sûr qu'on voudrait bien savoir
les premiers je pense mais on ne sait
pas y'a pas de soucis d'ia rien du tout
votre frère vous savez si posséder une
arme à feu
non non non il aimait la nature et tout
mais non il n'avait pas d'armes à feu à
l'heure actuelle rien ne lie cette mort
mystérieuse affaire alexia d'aval mais
la proximité géographique l'absence
d'armes et le fait que certains membres
des deux familles se connaissent et
tonne l'avocat du mari de la joggeuse
assassinée on a quelqu'un qui se
suicident à peu près deux mois et demi
après la découverte de du corps d'une
jeune femme qui a été tuée à quelques
centaines de mètres de l'endroit où ça
s'est passé dans un endroit extrêmement
calme où il se passe habituellement rien
à voir pas grand chose là ça fait
beaucoup
aujourd'hui le procureur de vesoul n'a
pas souhaité s'exprimer devant notre
caméra
mais il confirme que les deux affaires
ne sont pas liées